[Musica]
una sera mi chiamo mauro sono nato in
provincia di milano
ma sono napoletano sono nato lì classico
i miei genitori erano andati a lavorare
al nord però a 4 anni sono tornato a
napoli e it vurria vasà nella prima
canzone che ho sentito mia mamma priva
le finestre dalle persiane travi punti
con una stanza si illumina
per me
no anni dopo era d'inverno era anche una
brutta giornata più viva però mio padre
tornò euforico a casa entro in cucina e
si mise a cantare o sola cup
a chardin volontà io all'inizio non
avevo neanche riconosciuto che era la
stessa canzone perché mia mamma cantava
[Musica]
la cantava così perché l'aveva sentita
cantare così la sua madre da suo nonno
ed era un modo per tenere vivi i suoi
ricordi per dare voce dai fan tasti
anche mio padre l'aveva sentita cantare
in quel modo moderno da suo padre mio
nonno che non ho conosciuto ed era un
altro modo di dare voce ai fantasmi io
sono stato come ossessionato dai
fantasmi mi spaventavano mi tormentavano
sembrava quasi che volessero essere
ascoltati ma io non li ascoltavo fino al
giorno in cui nella mia vita è apparsa
questa scatola nera da allora ho
cominciato a pormi delle domande ma
perché la maniera di cantare di mio
padre era diversa da quella di mia madre
nell'ottocento come si cantava e poi più
in generale ma ma come è nata la canzone
napoletana canzone napoletana non è nata
a napoli
un po come me che sono napoletano ma
sono nato in provincia di milano
la canzone napoletana è nata a napoli
però alla sua diffusione hanno
contribuito in tanti francesi tedeschi
americani come nelle barzellette
ricordato c'era un francese un mezzo
tedesco un americano e tanti tanti
napoletani
e allora cominciamo dal francese si
chiamava gijon contro e all'inizio
dell'ottocento abitava a napoli questo
francese aveva tre qualità
la prima competenza musicale infatti si
occupava delle produzioni operistiche al
teatro di san carlo
la seconda parlava napoletano meglio di
un pescatore di abbasso bold e la terza
aveva una grande curiosità culturale ea
loro competenza musicale parlava
napoletano verace ed era pure curioso
che cosa formano queste tre qualità
un'ossessione million cutro era
ossessionato dalla cultura popolare
se ne andava in giro per i quartieri di
napoli e faceva cantare alle persone poi
annotava tutto sul suo taccuino poi
immaginatevi la scena lui si metteva
dietro le porte e origliava poi annotava
i versi le melodie ea napoli c'erano
centinaia di canzoni che il popolo aveva
custodito e tramandato però nessuno
aveva mai pensato di pubblicarle gijon
contro lo fece e a partire dal 1824
iniziò a pubblicare i suoi passatempi
musicali che fin dall'inizio contenevano
delle canzonette napoletane cioè lui
fece un po quello che fece omero preso
una tradizione orale la mise nero su
bianco
apache padrona crude
[Musica]
como
e adesso veniamo al mezzo tedesco mezzo
tedesco perché è nato in germania ma
naturalizzato negli stati uniti
am il berliner l'uomo che ha inventato
il disco io mi sono chiesto a lungo ma
come ha fatto berlin air senza microfoni
a imprigionare il suono in un oggetto in
un disco ha fatto così ha preso un
imbuto ci ha messo davanti un cantante
lo ha fatto cantare il suono si
espandeva entrava nell'imbuto arrivava
al diaframma che vi è brava e
trasmetteva l'informazione ad uno stilo
che incideva lacera e a questo punto il
suono era imprigionato in un oggetto e
per riascoltarlo bisognava essere
gentili con lo stesso stile bisognava
accarezzare il solco dove era nascosta
la musica la membrana di bra vari
trasmetteva l'onda sonora al corno
acustico e ritornava tutto a noi in
forma di musica ea dire semplice però la
procedura era complesse la formula era
segreta bisognava lavorare con cianuro
rane elettricità carta vetro a
manodopera litigare a levigare levigare
insomma ecco i primi dischi larghi 17 cm
neri non avevano etichette tutte le
informazioni erano graffiate nella
matrice e funzionavano e allora berliner
e di un'altra idea vendere i dischi e
qui arriviamo all'americano fred
gainsbourgh che era la gente di berlin
air e dato che era un agente girava per
il mondo perché perché doveva trovare
interpreti e materiali musicali per i
primissimi dischi lennon era un'impresa
facile perché immaginatevi prendere un
cantante magari anche celebre metterlo
davanti ad un imbuto senza pubblico e
farlo cantare ce n'erano alcuni che
arrivavano davanti all'imbuto tutti
truccati come all'opera però gaisberg
americano ciapi io a volontà e si mette
a girare il mondo questa è la mappa del
suo primo viaggio
new york hannover berlino san
pietroburgo voi vi starete chiedendo ma
che c'entra la canzone napoletana
il 29 giugno
nel 1900 flat di iceberg arriva al
napoli ed incide i primi 35 dischi di
canzoni napoletane sono i primi dischi
di canzone napoletana mai registrati a
napoli
naturalmente con accompagnamento di
chitarra e mandolino
sapete qual è la prima canzone
registrata a napoli maria mari e noi lo
facciamo ascoltare
[Musica]
il contenuto di questi primissimi dischi
alla fine dell'ottocento era
principalmente arie d'opera musica da
banda scenette comiche dei grammofoni si
trovavano i luoghi pubblici per esempio
bar ristoranti dove i clienti per
ascoltare la musica dovevano mettere
soldi un po come nei juke box canotto e
due voci però quel 29 giugno del 1900
quando fred gaisberg e arriva a napoli
nel retrobottega di un negozio inizia a
incidere le prime canzoni napoletane da
un impulso incredibile alla diffusione
della canzone napoletana
sì perché i dischi sono leggeri piccoli
possono viaggiare nel mondo arrivare
lontano in america oi marì
e poi marini qantas un giocatore
[Musica]
sapete che i primi dischi erano dischi
biologici quasi vegani sì perché il
contenuto e la materia prima dei primi
dischi era gommalacca e da dove viene la
gomma lacca da un insetto terry hall h
che vive in thailandia la femmina di
questo insetto produce una secrezione
che una volta purificata è la materia
prima della miscela dei dischi però la
gomma lacca era fragile e quindi il
contenuto di questi primi dischi era
fragilissime si rompevano molto spesso i
commercianti dell'epoca e non attenti
sia all'economia che all'ecologia e
allora invitavano i clienti a non
buttare i dischi rotti ma a riportarli
in magazzino perché si potevano
riciclare se ne potevano fare altre
stampe anzi se voi a casa avete per caso
dei dischi a 78 giri e non sapete che
farne si possono riciclare in un liquore
e dato che tutti oggi si danno alla
cucina
io vi ho portato la ricetta prendete una
pila di vecchi dischi a 78 giri però
fate attenzione perché saranno
l'etichetta di carta ci possono essere
possibile l'inchiostro allora meglio
dischi senza etichette sbriciolati i
dischi fino a ridurli a dadi e coprite
con litri d'acqua
poi fate bollire fino a quando la gomma
lacca è ammorbidita e lucida levate la
schiuma che si produce a filo d'acqua
rimuovere la bomba lacca e passare il
tutto attraverso un setaccio restituendo
i succhi spremuti alla ventola e
riservando la gomma lacca per altri usi
altri
fate raffreddare filtrate il tutto
attraverso diversi strati di stoffa per
formaggio misurate la quantità di
liquido rimanente e aggiungete una
quantità uguale di alcol di cereali
versate il liquore raffreddato in
barattoli di latta o altri pratici
contenitori per bere e e non beve niente
perché anche se tutto naturale è meglio
non fidarsi cioè bisogna zingara avanti
in abruzzo
colmata fatta mamma possaccio nei n
tutte queste cose 78 giri sulla storia
della canzone napoletana per me iniziato
tutto in una sera d'estate ero allievo
all'accademia di belle arti ed alcuni
compagni e dell'accademia mi invitarono
a cena e dopo cena
uno di loro portò questa scatola nera la
bri portò un disco di gomma lacca nera
una mise sul piatto
io all'epoca non avevo mai visto né un
grammofono né sentito il suono di un 78
giri
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
l'emozione è stata incredibile
sono rimasto immobile come se il
grammofono ha aperto le porte della mia
memoria mi ha fatto ascoltare per la
prima volta i fantasmi a partire da quel
giorno sono stato come ossessionato
iniziato a cercare 78 giri di canzoni
napoletane dappertutto nei mercatini dai
robivecchi metteva inserzioni sui
giornali andava a casa della gente come
contro era ossessionato
però mi che come oggi che ci sono le app
i mercatini online che si può comprare
su internet all epoca bisognava andare a
destra a sinistra camminare come
gaisberg e io dopo anni anni mi sono
ritrovato con centinaia di dischi a 78
giri tutti di canzoni napoletane molti
incisi a napoli però molti anche a
berlino a new york a buenos aires
insomma dove i napoletani erano andati
per cominciare nuove vite e quando ho
deciso di lasciare napoli per andare a
vivere a parigi non mi sono riusciti a
separare dei 78 giri ho deciso di
portarli tutti con me
voi pensate migliaia di dischi a 78 giri
centinaia e centinaia di ore di canzoni
due quintali che hanno viaggiato dal mio
appartamento di gioventù di napoli
ammassati in un camion hanno
attraversato le strade italiane la
frontiera francese per finire il loro
viaggio in un appartamento di parigi al
quarto piano
chiaramente senza ascensore due quintali
aveva casa piena di dischi erano
dappertutto persino in cucina e poi un
giorno a parigi una telefonata pronto da
roma un funzionario della discoteca di
stato che è un posto bellissimo dove non
si balla però si custodiscono dischi
aveva saputo di questa mia raccolta e
voleva che entrasse a far parte delle
collezioni della discoteca di stato io
chiaramente sono rimasto così vivi al
telefono mi diceva dobbiamo
digitalizzare tutti i rischi tutti i
dati devono diventare informazioni
metadati da mettere il sistema di ds pds
sia il sistema di di esser sistema
informatico di tutte le biblioteche del
sistema nazionale
io con l'entusiasmo accettato anche se
non mi era chiara questa storia di
metadati del ds l'ho capita insegue
in pratica di ogni disco che avevo
bisognava rintracciare tutte le
informazioni quando era stato registrato
il poeta che era il musicista se c'era
un'orchestra un direttore
i numeri di matrice ogni informazione è
vitale è però a volte sui miei dischi
c'era scritto il nome del cantante è il
titolo della canzone tutte le altre
informazioni bisognava ricercarle quindi
in pratica dove aver passato decina di
anni a cercare i dischi a 78 giri in
giro mi sono ritrovato a trascorrere gli
ultimi due anni a ricercare tutte le
informazioni di quei dischi il problema
è che di moltissime canzoni non si
sapeva niente non si sapeva chi erano
gli autori compositori poeti chant
comici sembravano tutti spariti nel
nulla
poi un po alla volta da una vecchia
enciclopedia da un catalogo da un
quotidiano del nome eurotec a da uno
scambio con un collezionista dischi in
cambio di informazioni sono iniziati ad
apparire i primi nomi cappelli teresina
chance resa lina soprano sottolana
eduardo baritono
donadio luigi paroliere de rosa raffaelo
tenore bendinelli ha puntato a per
antonio anna di alcuni non riuscivo
neanche
così a ricostituire il sesso però ogni
volta che trovavano informazione
relativa mio disco mettevo
l'informazione nel sistema informatico
trasformandola in un metadato e ogni
volta che andava online
avevo l'impressione che queste persone
tornassero in attività che cantassero
componessero creava una scuola nuova
scheda e diventava un metadato e devo
anche quasi la sensazione di sentire la
loro musica che non era stato inutile
quello che avevo fatto tutto ciò che
loro avevano fatto per la canzone
napoletana era di nuovo utile per
curiosi studiosi appassionati internauti
per noi
io non lo so che cosa servono le
passioni di ossessioni me lo sono
chiesto a lungo e la risposta l'ho
trovata una mattina a parigi nel nello
sguardo assonnato di mia figlia eva
quando non sapevo se svegliarle gettarla
nel mondo oppure lasciarla addormentata
sognare così e allora io ho cantato alla
stessa canzone che mi cantava mia mamma
quando ero bambino e io l'ho cantata
alla maniera antica di mia nonna e in
quel modo un po moderno di mio padre
l'ho fatto io ho cantato questa canzone
antica di più di cent'anni perché volevo
che le desse l'energia creativa per far
suonare il suo mondo in un modo nuovo
io taburno
[Applauso]
io
adorano
ho lasciato
è lasciata
io
[Musica]
auguri
io tu per me
[Musica]
napoli
no no
no grazie
[Applauso]